former congresswoman kelsey gabbard from
hawaii democrat joins us now
congresswoman great to see you uh i know
you just been out of the job for a week
or two are you surprised at pushing
forward with this
uh extra surveillance on would-be
domestic terror
uh it's so dangerous you know as you
guys have been talking about this is an
issue that all
democrats republicans independents
libertarians should be
extremely concerned about especially
because we don't have to guess
about where this goes or how this ends
when you have people like former cia
director john brennan
openly talking about how he's spoken
with
or heard from appointees and nominees in
the biden administration who are already
starting to look across our country
for these types of movements similar to
the insurgencies they've seen overseas
that in his words he says make up this
unholy alliance of
religious extremists racists
bigots uh he lists a few others and adds
at the end
even libertarians so
when you look at their process and they
start looking at okay how do what
characteristics are we looking for is
we're building this profile
of a potential extremist uh what are we
talking about
religious extremists are we talking
about uh christians evangelical
christians what is it
what is a religious extremist is it
somebody who's pro-life i mean what
where do you where do you take this uh
you start looking at
okay well obviously you have to be a
white person obviously
likely male libertarians well if anybody
who loves freedom
liberty maybe has an american flag
outside their house or
uh people who you know attended a trump
rally uh once you start walking this
down the path you see where it leads to
a
very dangerous undermining of our civil
liberties
our freedoms in our constitution and
a targeting of almost half of the
country you and omar says this
um we already have laws on the book
sorry but you are just going to have to
learn to apply them the other thing i
thought was interesting
uh congresswoman i don't see any fbi
demanding more tools
they feel they got the tools these are
these are congressional leaders or
members
who feel as though they're so they're so
freaked out by trump supporters they
still can't understand
why anyone would support him they want
to get to the bottom of it and do you
think the whole deep programming of
trump supporters this new buzzword
among uh detractors and democrats has
anything to do with this
uh yeah i think it does very directly i
think just on the fbi front i read a
great op-ed this morning from a former
fbi agent who made a very strong case
for
why this new domestic terror law
introduced by adam schiff is wrong and
and is is directly going to undermine
our constitutional rights and freedoms
um this whole effort whether you're
talking about this bill
or people saying that we have to
de-program these these trump
cultists and people who voted for trump
because they've been radicalized
all of this just goes to further tear
our country apart
and it moves towards the thing joe biden
said in his inauguration speech that
that he shouldn't happen which is a
dehumanization
of your opponent and that's where his
voice is so necessary right now he is
the president of this country
he delivered this speech his voice
himself speaking to the american people
he needs to denounce people like john
brennan and their statements
bills like the one adam schiff put
forward and truly speak to the american
people about how we must
come together around you know the
constitution around our bill of rights
around these rights that have been
endowed to us by our creator
if he had your leadership ability he
would do it maybe he still will
that's why she ran for president
congresswoman tulsi gabbard thanks so
much
thank you brian i